bonjour la voie est libre tous les
samedis en direct sur france 3 avec
aujourd'hui quatre voies pour débattre
d'un sujet qui vu de paris ou de
certaines grandes villes semble
incroyable et pourtant une partie de la
population aujourd'hui et privés ou
quasiment privés d'internet autour de
cette table
patrice joly président socialiste du
conseil départemental de la nièvre
bonjour dont jaune
ludovic rochette vice président les
républicains du conseil départemental de
côte-d'or en charge du numérique vous
est aussi président des maires de
côte-d'or bonjour bonjour à vous cédric
coll fond vous êtes président de pc là
est une association qui dans l'yonne
intervient justement pour aider les
oubliés d'internet bonjour bonjour et
benoît vidaud vous êtes le président de
la cgpme de côte-d'or parce que les
artisans et les entreprises sont aussi
bien sûr très concerné par ce sujet
bonjour bonjour à vous signalons que
l'opérateur orange en première ligne sur
ce dossier n'a pas voulu participer à
cette émission alors que nous l'avions
invité
et si vous le souhaitez et que vous avez
un petit peu de réseaux vous pouvez de
plus chez vous réagir sur notre site
internet
dans l'article consacré à l'émission
nous répondrons à vos questions il y en
a déjà qui sont tombés je le disais le
sujet toujours d'actualité avec par
exemple la semaine dernière une pétition
signée dans plusieurs villages du morvan
cvo patrice joly qu'il l'avait portée de
cette pétition a été amené un opérateur
écouter d'abord les témoignages dans un
de ces villages à fâches un bain au mois
d'août par exemple dix minutes pour
afficher une page internet
donc là ça commence à bien faire on
s'oblige or ce contre à répondre aux
clients dans la journée et là
effectivement au bout d'une semaine on a
des clients qui nous rappelle en disant
écoutez moi j'ai pas une de vos
nouvelles dont je pense qu'on perd de
cette façon on perd des clients et en
ondées favorise l'économie locale on
soit une petite mairie ou dans nos
mairies on nous demande de travailler
avec cet outil exactement de la même
manière qu'une grande ville ils font pas
la différence et quand l'outil est pas
encore en état de marche bien on peut on
peut fermer la mairie certaines journées
alors je le disais patrice joly s'est
porté cette pétition c'est chez vous
c'est dans la nièvre est ce que c'est
représentatif réellement de ce qui se
passe dans votre département
ah ben si représentatif de ce qui se
passe sur un certain nombre de communes
du territoire départemental c'est à dire
que france les communes écoles à
l'époque orange vend des abonnements et
ne porte pas le service et cette
initiative qui est propre aux habitants
de la commune de vache un qui a fait un
peu tache d'huile et les habitants ont
décidé de venir porter leur
mécontentement auprès de leurs
représentants
et donc ils m'ont ils m'ont contacté je
les ai reçus et je leur ai dit écoutez
le plus simple c'est que on est ensemble
à la direction régionale d'orange pour
faire part de la satisfaction et leur
demander de répondre à leurs obligations
contractuelles c'est à dire vous fournir
un service satisfaisant matière de
téléphonie et d'internet
on va reparler mais la réponse d'orange
passe addison dû tourner c'est
dommageable parce que on à l'opérateur
qui nous dit bas sur une pas contents
allez voir plutôt l'opérateur voisins je
résume un peu je pense pas trahir les
propose quand même assez surprenant où
se retournant vers la collectivité
publique
ainsi on vend à un abonnement on se doit
de donner services correspondants cet
abonnement on va y revenir bien sûr
benoît vidaud on a entendu des gens des
professionnels qui parlait vous ça vous
remonte beaucoup vous présidez la cgpme
en côte d'or ce genre de situation des
gens qui ont pas des bic ont pas de
raison qu'ils peuvent plus satisfaire
d'ailleurs à des obligations
administratives aujourd'hui un oui alors
ça la campagne évidemment c'est un vrai
problème mais même à dijon je vous en
parlerai juste après le non accès
internet ne l'accès de la téléphonie
dans des zones où en plus on voudrait
accueillir des entreprises pour
maintenir de l'emploi et des services
c'est un petit peu antinomique parce que
pour accueillir des entreprises et
qu'elles restent dans ces territoires
ruraux
il faut se permettre de leur donner les
moyens de pouvoir faire leur métier
correctement tout simplement et on a
évidemment des grosse problématique
d'entreprise qui se déplace ou
qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas les moyens de
répondre à leurs clients à leurs
activités et à des déclarations qui sont
afférents ligne cédric colson est ce
qu'il ya une différence entre eux ce qui
est affiché et le réel dans votre
expérience
on a eu des remontées sur notre site
internet là dessus de jean dix ans mais
nous on nous garantit qu'on aura de
l'internet en réalité les chiffres sont
faux il ya plein d'endroits où il y en a
pas risquent eux c'est vrai mais on
constate sur sur le territoire de
l'yonne là où là on travaille qui a
énormément de 2,2 besoin
l'élément de son sont identiques à ce
que vous lisez dans les communes les
entreprises les gens et s'aperçoit de
très clair donc c'est ça correspond pas
à la réalité
les pourcentages haut niveau au niveau
du territoire reflète pas la réalité et
qui sont spécifiques à une petite
commune cc c'est compliqué oui dans un
département comme le vos clients vous
estimez à ce que c'est possible
d'estimer le pourcentage de gens qui
voudraient avoir d'internet qui
n'annoncent pas je n'aurai pas de
chiffres précis précis à donner parce
qu'ils pourront être interprété
différemment
donc je n'aurai pas de chiffres précis
peut-être que les collectors ordonnée on
a du mal à les avoir ces chiffres les
avis crochète vous vous occupez du
numérique au conseil départemental de
côte-d'or ces chiffres par exemple le
département pour la côte-d'or vous les
avez vous les connaissez bien sûr on a
fait une étude avec les services du
département on était début 2015 avec sur
7 106 communes 300 communes qui
n'avaient pas de méga ce qui nous a
poussés à nous tourner prioritairement
vers ces communes là avec d'un système
de montée en débit pour que ces communes
puissent avoir d'ici 2017
donc le triple play c'est-à-dire le
plein et c'est à dire quinze liga pour
avoir téléphone internet télévision
alors là dans ce cas là quand vous dites
on monte en débit ça veut dire quoi
concrètement que les gens le comprennent
bien c'est vous qui payez pour que ya
plus de débit vous mettez quoi des
transformateurs des amplificateurs enfin
- alors on comprend rien quand il
faisant très simple
on a deux zones dans chaque département
des zones amis là où il ya un opérateur
qui va intervenir en investissant orange
côte d'or 6 sur l'agglomération de dijon
et sur beaune et les collectivités
peuvent intervenir dans les zones
extérieures ce qu on appelle les zones
mon ami c'est là où département
intervient avec deux techniques ce qu'on
appelle le ftth c'est à dire la fibre
qui arrivent là vous parlez de fibres
déjà on est déjà dans de la fibre on est
on est plus dans les raisons anciens le
réseau téléphonique pour l'adsl alors ça
c'est oublier déjà non je fis le chan
pardon premières n'auraient sagres en
france prières moi seul ftth donc la
fille karine juste à domicile où l
entreprise avec la prise et là on a des
zones par exemple vermont barbarie sur
tille qui ont été ciblés et puis
d'autres comme une glace et la montée en
débit c'est à dire quand on tire la
fibre jusqu'à l'entrée du village
et après on va utiliser ce système
cuivre et l'aria nouvelle technique
s'appelle le vdsl2 qui permet de booster
avec avec le cuivre ce qui va te
permettre pour nous en même temps c'est
75 millions d'euros
donc c'est pas anecdotique de traiter
les communes qui n'ont pas de méga mais
aussi de traiter des zones qui ont
besoin a besoin absolu de très haut
débit par exemple mon bar avec avec les
entreprises
patrice de vie c'est là une situation
pour vous depuis 2005 dans la nièvre
vous aviez fait le choix d'une structure
en fait pour ça oui quel rôle elle a
joué qu est ce que vous avez fait pour
essayer de compenser je vous avoue
essayer de compenser justement le les à
satisfaction liée au fait que les
opérateurs interviennent pas sur le
département de manière satisfaisante
orange en particulier donc on a mis en
place une boucle numérique haut débit
une boucle qui permet effectivement de
desservir un certain nombre de faits la
plupart des cantons du département de
manière à augmenter justement le débit
internet et parallèlement à ça nous
avons mis en place ce qu'on appelle un
dispositif wimax à lire en fête du wifi
élargie sur le territoire pour aller
desservir par le hertzien l'apa par le
cuivre desservir les entreprises des
habitants qui ont besoin de un débit
d'un débit suffisant pour un abonnement
qui est un abonnement équivalent à
l'abonnement
aujourd'hui proposés par les opérateurs
et là par exemple les communes qui ont
déposé cette pétition fachin par exemple
ça veut dire qu'elles sont pas
desservies par ce que vous avez fait ni
par les opérateurs ni par vous on ne pas
desservir ne sont pas desservis l'un
parce qu'elle était censée desservir
correctement par l'opérateur
est ce que c'est vrai qu'en réalité les
opérateurs disent pas toute la vérité
sur leur capacité à couvrir
on n'arrive pas à avoir les informations
de manière très correcte sur les heures
de rétention d'information il ya surtout
des investissement minimal qui pourrait
être fait sur un certain nombre
d'équipements qui permettrait de monter
en débit
pour vous donner une petite idée il ya
quelques temps avait à peu près
identifiée qui avait 30 endroit dans le
département pour être simple ou avec un
accident entre trois et cinq mille euros
orange pouvait augmenter le débit de
manière satisfaisante de manière
significative de la part des abonnés
pour un montant global qui est de leurs
deux cent cinquante mille euros que je
veux comparer aux 1 milliard d'euros de
bénéfices d'orange
oui et on ça permettait d'améliorer le
service pour dix mille foyers ou en tout
cas de 10000 prises qui n'est pas rien
c'est 20 à 30000 habitants
alors on redira que orange qui va en
prendre pour son grade pendant toute
cette émission n'a pas voulu participer
à l'émission alors qu'on qu'on les avait
invités benoît milot vous étiez en train
d'agresser au décalage entre le coup peu
important de l'équipement et les
bénéfices oui oui parce que nos 36 ans
vos chefs d'entreprise de pme ils
réagissent comment ils ne comprennent
pas ils comprennent pas parce que nous
on n'est pas là en train de demander
tout aux collectivités tout le temps
avec justement des moyens qui sont de
moins en moins important un acteur aussi
important qu orange aujourd'hui avec le
résultat net dont on vient parler se
doit d'équipé de territoire pour pouvoir
demain rayonner encore plus et c'est
aussi dans son intérêt de main de deux
fours pour les consommateurs d'internet
je voudrais rebondir sur une chose qui a
été dit tout de suite
enfin qui dit tout à l'heure on parlait
de campagne on parlait de dijon vous
avez envie de parler d'eux oui j'ai
envie d'en parler parce que c'est pas
seulement la campagne aujourd'hui à
dijon on veut être la capitale d'une
grande région demain et nous allons
créer des pôles tertiaires comme valmy
valmy 3 que vous connaissez qui
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir accueillir des
entreprises de manière exogènes
c'est des entreprises qui viennent
d'ailleurs ont besoin de la fibre valmy
n'a pas la fibre le très très haut débit
à valmy
n'y est pas c'est quand même fou quand
on fait des parcs tertiaires de cette
envergure alors que la fibre est mise à
disposition de certains logements dans
les programmes de logement mais la fibre
je pense qu'il y avait une priorité pour
l'emploi l'entreprise s'était déjà
d'équiper les zones tertiaires qui
accueille des entreprises demain qui
veulent s'installer qui refusent de
s'installer à valmy d'ailleurs y en a
certains qui disent ah bah non pas de
fibres pas très haut débit pas dijon
donc si on veut vraiment être attractif
et si on veut vraiment venir faire des
voeux venir des entreprises ici à dijon
et créer de l'emploi et bien
effectivement solar qu'on sait qu'ils
paient de la fibre sur les grands pôles
tertiaires cédric colson au jour le jour
vous dans votre intervention ce qu'on va
leur dire vous répondez aux gens qui
disaient moi j'arrive pas avoir internet
et vous qu'est-ce d'abord qu'est ce que
vous venez proposez-vous on a entendu ce
que vous et les collectivités
qu'est ce que vous faites nous notre
notre action elle est simple on s'est
dit tout simplement va pas attendre
parce que c'est compliqué les opérateurs
nationaux ça demande du temps à sa
demande de l'argent nos élus ils sont
empêtrés un petit peu dans tout ça parce
que l'argent public on sait qu'un a pas
beaucoup et c'est compliqué faut pas le
dépenser n'importe comment et donc les
gens viennent nous voir en disant mais
voilà pc live vous proposer de l'accès
internet là où il y en a pas vous faites
du très haut débit et ça coûte pas cher
comment vous faites c'est dit tout
simplement on se prend en main et on va
on va se mettre ensemble pour faire
avancer les choses
non pas contre le département dit
content les opérateurs c'est juste qu'on
veut pas attendre cinq dix quinze ans
pour faire des choses est très
régulièrement on a des collectivités et
des communes des entreprises qui
viennent nous voir pour répondre à des
besoins spécifiques
parce qu'ils sont dans des zones
blanches ou alors très mal desservi on
va dire que vous êtes dans un
département qui a pris du retard par
rapport à d'autres
je pense qu'on n'est pas en tête de
peloton loin de là dans le département
de l'yonne malheureusement et on veut
faire avancer les choses quitte à
bousculer les consciences les opérateurs
et les élus pour faire avancer les
choses
concrètement vous avez donné de
l'internet à combien de foyers là
aujourd'hui on à 183 personnes en deux
ans donc ça peut paraître dérisoire ça
peut paraître peu mais c'est 183 foyer
qui n'avaient pas accès du tout internet
et combien de demandes 183 équipés en ce
moment combien de demandes il faut
savoir c'est compliqué aussi nous ça
demande du temps pour pouvoir installer
un relais parce que on travaille avec
des ombres sienne comme le disait
monsieur en gros vous passez pas par le
sol par les câbles vous passez par le
ciel on a une partie avec des cas parce
qu'on peut pas faire autrement la
technique des technologies
dsl qui nous aide bien on a deux fibres
qui sont qui sont tirées pour
l'association
et puis après on utilise des relais donc
des châteaux d'eau des églises des
points hauts pour faire passer cet
internet par là par la voie des ondes
radio dénommée prochaine voulait réagir
pour l'indigence totale
oui parce que dans votre introduction
vous avez parlé dès que c'est un sujet
un peu surprenant pour les grandes
villes et effectivement on a déjà des
quartiers dans l'agglomération
dijonnaise on a des zones d'activités
dans l'agglomération dijonnaise qui ont
souci on peut parler aussi de cap nord
et là nous avons une convention avec
orange poursuivre le déploiement
poursuivre le déploiement parce que nous
n'avons pas la compétence financière
pour pouvoir intervenir aujourd'hui dans
ces zones
et force est de constater que je vous
dis beaucoup plus pour comprendre
est ce que ça signifie par exemple qu'un
opérateur comme orange d'autres par
exemple n'est pas intéressé par des
parcs d'entreprises ou des zones
technologie parce que ça fait moins
d'abonnement que des immeubles avec des
avec beaucoup de prises est ce que c'est
ça que ça veut dire est qu'ils ont
parentis ils ont pas souhaité déployer
sur leur politique de déploiement je
n'ai pas répondre au nom de l'opérateur
apparemment c'est sûrement une petite
apparemment c'est pas la logique de cet
opérateur s'est pas la logique par
contre c'est là c'est la logique des
collectivités qui aujourd'hui va
s'occuper de leurs zones où elles
peuvent intervenir financièrement dans
département ce sont 68 zone d'activités
qui vont être dotés d'un dc donc 2017 de
ce débit le très haut débit on va y
venir parce que c'est un autre enjeu on
va dire c'est peut-être l'étagé
supérieur de la fusée
j'avais envie de vous poser une question
patrice joly on sait que vous vous êtes
beaucoup investi sur la ruralité
quand on parle d'internet il ya ce
concept de fracture numérique est ce
qu'elle a et vous avez sûrement tous un
avis là dessus des conséquences
politiques d'une certaine manière est ce
que quand les gens vivent à la campagne
travail à la campagne on l'a eu le
sentiment de ne pas être traités comme
les autres
est ce que est ce que c'est exagéré de
mettre ça en regard avec par exemple la
montée du vote extrême dans les zones
rurales
si tu as des éléments qui
le sentiment effectivement d'être
relégué des usagers des administrés de
seconde zone de secondes horde en
quelque sorte c'est devenu réalité j'ai
d'ailleurs nuit là la orange devant ses
responsabilités en disant qu en tant
qu'entreprise également ça n'est pas
neutre sur le plan effectivement dur
sentiers donc de la réaction politique
permettez moi aussi de dire que
s'agissant effectivement les territoires
ruraux on marche un peu sur la tête sur
ce secteur-là comme sur d'autres
secteurs où il n'ya pas de concurrence
où la concurrence est très mauvaise
franchement aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
c'est qu'on a des opérateurs qui
investit soir qui surinvestissent
parfois dans les zones très denses très
rentable et qui sous investissent
ailleurs franchement aujourd'hui la
meilleure manière de desservir
correctement le territoire s'arrêter à
un opérateur unique
je suis pour l'économie de marché
lorsqu'elle fonctionne lorsqu'il ya une
multitude d'offres qui en face à une
multitude de demandes
ça n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui la
meilleure solution ce serait en tout cas
ce qu'il faudrait et ça pour est une
initiative que l'on prenne dans les
temps qui viennent c'est qu'on
reconstruise au moins sur les zones
rurales celles qui sont pas dans les
zones amis c'est à dire confié à des
opérateurs qu'on construise un grand
réseau national de coopération entre
toutes les initiatives départementales
ou régionales qui vont être prises
prochainement
en tout cas c'est un appel que je lance
aujourd'hui parce que je crois qu'on
aurait ainsi une force une expertise
financière technique et nous permettrait
de peser sur cet enjeu de société qui
est très important à la fois pour le
développement économique mais également
sur le plan politique sachant que je
vous lis à haute voix les
les propositions de statuts de la
nouvelle loi numérique est en discussion
en ce moment par la secrétaire d'état au
numérique c'est d'ailleurs contributif
les gens ont plus contribué
il est question de liberté égalité
fraternité d'un fraternité il est écrit
parce que l'accès de chacun au réseau
répond à un impératif républicain de
solidarité et d'inclusion des citoyens
il sera une priorité du projet de loi
ça veut donc dire que normalement
l'accès au réseau devrait être un peu
comme une distance d'une maternité ou
d'un service d'urgence mais si vraiment
le principe d'égalité de fraternité
c'est je veux un mode lancée il pas s'y
plier à notre volonté aussi de
développer les territoires ruraux pour
ce qu'ils peuvent avoir apporté à leur
population et ce qu'ils peuvent apporter
comme contribution au développement
notre pays on a dans ce pays on a le
plus bel espace rural en europe avec
l'ensemble de ses ressources à la fois
naturelle ou humaine
il faut qu'on puisse avoir les moyens de
développer effectivement la technologie
numérique est indispensable c'est vrai
que son jeu vous voyez à créer s'est
complètement d'accord avec ça crée de la
frustration les gens sont frustrés ils
viennent acheter une propriété à la
campagne ils demandent pas si ado
électricité c'est évident et demande
s'il ya internet considère que c'est un
droit fondamental au même titre que
l'accès à l'eau potable électricité et
ça crée de la frustration rapport aux
grandes villes qui sont parfois pas
toujours bien lotis mais en règle
générale ça va beaucoup mieux en ville
il ya aussi une forme d'ambiguïté
ludovic rochette parce que vous disiez
c'est un droit fondamental comme l'eau
comme tout ça ça fait très longtemps que
tout le monde a décidé que c'était
d'abord une marchandise l'accès internet
oui mais quand vous êtes sur un
territoire touristique et voulait
accueillir des touristes
quelles sont la première demande outre
les monuments quand il choisit d
hébergement il voulait choisir par
rapport à la connexion internet par
rapport à la téléphonie mobile a
aujourd'hui c'est un facteur qu'on ne
peut pas oublier
et deuxième chose c'est que si les
collectivités aujourd'hui sont obligés
d'investir
elles le sont parce qu'il faut bien
quelqu'un fasse quelque chose
aujourd'hui pour nos territoires dans
une situation économique assez compliqué
est néanmoins c'est un ballon d'oxygène
pour les entreprises parce que
conseil général 75 millions d'euros
d'investissements sur trois ans ces 75
millions d'euros pour les entrevues pour
les entreprises d'acheter de cowes
benoît vidéo ce que vient de dire pas
très joli c'est à dire est ce que ce
serait pas l'occasion de mettre tout le
monde ensemble décidé de fédérer des
initiatives est ce que c'est typiquement
le genre de choses que je vous de votre
côté vous aimeriez même moi je ne suis
que d'accord sur escaut clairement le
haut débit d'internet et choses comme ça
ça autant fait l'objet de guerre et de
flingage entre collectivités depuis des
décennies que de coopération moi je ne
remets pas là encore une fois genre mais
le débat où je vous l'avait posée tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que pour moi ce
n'est pas de la responsabilité des
collectivités donné le haut débit
on a des opérateurs qui se substitue à
un opérateur national qui doit faire son
travail
aujourd'hui la collectivité elle doit
donner le cadre et créer des zones
susceptibles d'accueillir des
entreprises et l'opérateur doit faire
son travail
l'opérateur unique pour structurer un
territoire et puis pour demain pourquoi
pas si c'est la solution si c'est la
solution de demain avoir un programme
très ambitieux avec un opérateur unique
qui va demain irriguer les campagnes et
certaines grandes zones économiques de
grandes villes également puisqu'il n'ya
pas que les campagnes qui ont besoin
d'autre chose pour pouvoir créer de
l'emploi créé de l'emploi en réalité
c'est très important de maintenir les
entreprises
on parlait du nord côte-d'or tout à
l'heure montbard semur châtillon etc
il ya un bassin d'emploi qui en train de
de s'amenuiser parce que les entreprises
ont du mal à rester également et
internet fait partie des pas uniquement
mais fait partie des choses qui
pourraient maintenir l'entreprise en
réalité est ce que ça signifie quand
même que certains de l'entreprise elle
paye en plus ou ruy voir le haut débit
avoir de l'intranet se faire leur propre
réseau en réalité charges inutiles des
charges inutiles pour des petites
entreprises déjà en difficulté qui
doivent payer en plus pour avoir un
internet correct et pas performant
correct une heure pour ouvrir une page
comme les habitants ou s'ils paient le
même abonnement que tout le monde pour
le triple play c'est-à-dire le téléphone
internet télévision et moi je dans mon
village je paye pour les trois jean
n'est que 2 et avec un débit qui est pas
toujours se disent en tout cas
irrégulier parce que c'est un élément
aussi tient parfois y affectant être
difficultés d'accès mais il a surtout
des difficultés liées en fait avoir un
service de qualité en continu et c'est
très dommage à vous pariez sur les
questions de touristique moi j'ai des
restaurateurs en fait des gens qui
travaillent dans le tourisme c'est elle
qui ont eu des difficultés parce que
pendant plusieurs heures voire plusieurs
jours ils ne pouvaient pas utiliser la
carte bleue tout simplement service
était défaillant comme on fait vu paris
ça semble effectivement assez incroyable
et s'accroche et c'est vrai qu'on avait
pris du retard en bourgogne
là le temps moyen de connexion le temps
moyen c'est c'est cette seconde
donc ça va deux d'une heure jusqu'à
jusqu'à une seconde mais ça veut dire
qu'on avait pris quand même du retard il
faut faire notre autocritique on a aussi
beaucoup tergiversé entre élus pour
savoir quelle était la technique que
l'on voulait l'adopter je crois que
maintenant ce temps et finit d'ailleurs
que c'est vrai que longtemps les élus
n'ayant rien compris et que beaucoup s'y
sont pas intéressés je pense plutôt que
les élus et les opérateurs se sont
regardés et puis ben aujourd'hui on est
à un seuil on ne peut plus attendre et
c'est vrai ce que disait benoît vidaud
c'est pas la collectivité normalement de
le faire aujourd'hui si personne ne fait
ça suffit pas donc les collectivités au
prix 120 et puis je voulais la preuve
aussi que les élus l'ont bien compris
c'est que les élus d'autres départements
aujourd'hui s'associent dans la société
publique locale qui va vous amener au
chapitre suivant je voulais juste quand
même parce que je vouvoyais sourire
quand je dis certain nombre d'élus
comprenait pas grand chose et ce qui
intéressait pas allez on va pas on va
pas mentir mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des
gens qui viennent vous demander leur
expliquer des élus qui viennent le monde
et on le respecte mais c'est tout à leur
honneur parce que l'opérateur orange
vient en disant oh là là ça coûte très
très cher la feep c'est très très
compliqué vous savez vaut mieux attendre
est ce que vous pouvez faire le
nécessaire pour qu'on ait des
subventions il faut il faut que la
collectivité agissent comme ci comme ça
donc les élus il est quoi qu'on en dise
c'est compliqué il essaye de comprendre
et puis temps en temps il y en a qui
viennent nous voir les gens vont mal
écoutez là les petits gars expliquez moi
moi j'ai pas bien compris et on leur
explique ce c'est pas si compliqué que
ça
effectivement que ça peut coûter cher
mais que c'est pas si compliqué que ça
on voudrait bien leur faire croire oui
mais je veux dire c'est que le plus
compliqué et c'était des compétences
qu'on n'avait pas dans nos collectivités
ou les acquise il ya dix ans d'un règne
avons il faisait partie des premiers
départements mais pourquoi parce qu'on
était plus
train que les fonds parce que
l'opérateur intervenait beaucoup moins
bien qu'ailleurs mais il ya des
compétences non seulement technique avec
des alternances ils sont importantes sur
les modèles économiques qu est-ce qui
sur le long terme effectivement permet
de rentabiliser au mieux
l'investissement qu'on réalise
c'était autant de compétences qu'on
n'avait pas il a fallu les acquérir pour
pouvoir être des interlocuteurs valables
face aux opérateurs qui ont toutes les
cartes dans les mains très son sac
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur
les sur la réalité des chiffres
vous parliez effectivement de la
coopération entre conseils
départementaux parce que c'est vrai que
et d'ailleurs c'était des raisons de
notre volonté de faire cette émission il
y avait des exemples ruraux il ya aussi
ce qui se passe dans les conseils
départementaux en ce moment avec la
création d'une structure beaucoup plus
vaste à propos du très haut débit
effectivement ça les gens ne savent pas
non plus
c'est la nouvelle étape on va essayer
d'être très très simple très caricatural
en gros avant on utilisait le réseau
téléphone maintenant pour avoir du très
haut débit faut créer en gros un nouveau
réseau avec de la fibre
donc il va falloir poser le réseau dans
un certain nombre d'endroits là où les
opérateurs n'iront pas qu'il faudra
après on en parlera aussi exploiter tout
ça on est surpris de voir que par
exemple
moi j'ai appris ça dans un département
comme le vôtre l'yonne le plus gros
opérateur orange pour ne pas le citer
mais intéressé que par auxerre et sens
et n'est même pas intéressé par une
communauté de communes comme joigny on
tombe quand même de l'armoire quand on
apprend ça agricole est question de
rentabilité tout simplement c'est aussi
simple que ça il ya des actionnaires
derrière on va à les arroser là où il ya
beaucoup de personnes est typiquement là
où il n'y a pas besoin de débit
puisqu'il est déjà pas trop mal quoi et
on va laisser derrière tout ce qui est
pas intéressant faut pas honte de le
dire c'est la vérité on est dans des
enjeux purement économique
et ça veut donc dire que là c'est les
collectivités parce que ce qui est en
train de se mettre en place tout le
monde le dit les collectivités sont en
train de monter des plans de financement
pour déployer la fibre mais donc ça veut
quand même dire que quand ces
départements régions europe états qui
paient une installation du réseau
c'est des citoyens qui sont en train de
payer leur installation de réseaux on
est tous d'accord là-dessus d'accord
peut-être lire que orange regarde son
actionnaire californien est pas du tout
la bonne et bruyant quand même faut que
je sois clair c'est ça on en est là hein
ça oblige effectivement les colistiers
intervenir
montrer les enjeux dans départements
l'allier fc 250 millions d'euros pour
pouvoir desservir l'ensemble du
territoire
faut dire que le budget d'investissement
du conseil départemental tout compris il
routes collèges et cédera ses 50 à 60
millions d'euros par an ça vous montre
le niveau de la marche à apporter d'où
l'idée effectivement de travailler
ensemble et on essaie de travailler à
travers le un investissement qui
seraient portés par les collectifs
exploité par une société qu'on aura au
comment au niveau département
bourguignon et deux départements de
franche-comté
mais là aussi tout ça est compliqué
puisqu'on n'a pas fait les mêmes choix
au départ le monte de la montée en débit
pour la côte d'or la création d'une
réseau propre pour le département nièvre
l'articulation d'un peu complexe à la
fois sur le plan juridique et économique
donc mon nid travail parce qu'on a envie
d'aboutir vous le disiez tout à l'heure
lors tout à l'heure on parler d'internet
n'est très haut débit c'est un enjeu
économique majeur aux majeurs majeure
pour les grandes villes et même même la
ruralité demain mais l'enjeu c'est
aujourd'hui de pouvoir accueillir des
entreprises dans nos grandes villes
qu'ils puissent et qui ont besoin et
qu'ils ne viendront pas de toute façon
s'il n'y a pas ce très haut débit elles
resteront à paris où ali c'est ce que
demande une entreprise quand elle a
envie de s'installer quelques parcs
bon il ya le confort de vie ya un
certain nombre de choses mais très haut
débit ça vient d'en qu'elle rend très
haut débit je pense que ça vient pas
loin du premier en pas loin du premier
rang c'est vrai pour les entreprises
c'est vrai pour les habitants si on veut
développer le télétravail dans nos
territoires comme veut le faire l'état
actuellement dans le cadre de la fusion
des régions si j'ai bien compris il faut
qu' il faut soutenir les collectivités
pour que l'on puisse travailler dans
toutes les communes c'est effectivement
excuse-moi ludot on a aujourd'hui les
pme dans la difficulté on les met
souvent en face de leurs responsabilités
orange grand groupe national français
devraient en fasse des siennes dans la
difficulté qui est la nôtre d'irrigation
du territoire la revue on leur a proposé
de venir vous parle nous on est on est
je suis un peu abasourdi de deux des
quelques informations j'ai là puisqu'on
sait que c'est très compliqué mais
effectivement quand on parle que de
rentabilité pour ce besoin qui est
devenu un besoin prioritaire pour
l'entreprise et l'économie française je
pense qu'on devrait aussi les mettre en
face de leurs responsabilités de manière
plus forte puisque c'est pas les
résultats qui manquent pour pouvoir un
programme pour avoir un programme
d'investissements ambitieux pour nos
territoires
je pense que le problème n'est pas là
donc effectivement nous on fait les
efforts dans l'eau pme ont fait des
efforts depuis très longtemps
ils doivent en faire également on parler
d'internet vous vous amener l'internet
mais c'est light mais maintenant on va
vous demander là haut débit vous allez
pouvoir l'amener très haut débit c'est à
partir de 30 mégas donc nous quand on
prend du vdsl où on a eu l'adduction
fibres de toute façon on amène du très
haut débit
donc il ya des gens qui étaient
stupéfaits savez un méga par l'opérateur
historique et puis l'on en fin de
journée on les installe et happy partent
à 30 mégas 40 méga cinq rôles c'est à
dire dans les deux sens
le ils sont actuellement stupéfait faut
savoir aussi que les usages ont évolué
énormément les besoins ne sais pas le
même internet aujourd'hui qu'il ya dix
ans pour les particuliers les
entreprises
vous êtes sont décédés par des
entreprises aussi ben oui bas valais les
mêmes conditions une petite entreprise
qui va aller demander à orange pour
paris cité du très haut débit on va lui
donner une facture de 5000 euros va
essayer de trouver une autre solution
pour un artisan 5000 euros c'est pas
possible d'entendre parler de nous et
puis on ne va et puis si ça fonctionne
on le fait c'est merveilleux on va
continuer à parler du très haut débit
dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission on parlera aussi de ce que l'on
parle du réseau par du film mais de
comment ça va marcher après parce que ce
que les gens ignorent c'est que faudra
aussi que quelqu'un s'occupe de ce clip
de ce réseau on parlera de ça et puis
des questions vous nous avez posé sur le
site internet de france 3 dans l'article
consacré à l'émission on en a plusieurs
et compris quelques cas pratique pour
les élus on parle de ça juste après les
informations de midi une poignée de
minutes pour tout savoir sur ce qui
s'est passé dans la région et nous on se
retrouve juste après a tout de suite